goes in front of bosski C field Monahan back to
Cole Coffield he'll work it across bom mat right
on and handled by Bovi on the buck for Gallagher
Gallagher using the board speeds Baron UL back
to Baron wrist shot High Gallagher looking for
anything but barski here's Rodriguez stretching
ice up to the right side for the captain barov
the L throws it in front spinning try Oliver
emman Larson was breaking in from the blue line
and a good look on Primo eblad hit his skate
Monahan around the boards linan chasing after it
there's new hook lenan gets in his face but mat
for Suzuki in front oh the one headed TI mad out
of midair two chances from Sha Monahan who has
been a bit snake bitten no goals for Monahan in
his last 12 such pressure and great recognition
someone's open down low in that little pass bonan
rather than stop it just tole Ed it up and then
got the second one out of the air Cole Coffield
had it lost it look out rarts on the move with
barov barkov there first barov Reinhardt and a
kick stop by Primo Baron goes back down low to
anen and now it's going the other way back with
Florida they get their three-on-one opportunity
and maton got back and helped him out and the
stick tap from mat into Primo HS the other way
Coffield tough angle shot and it was handled
by bosski Cole Coffield top 10 in the NHL in
shots on goal he'll fire from anywhere and another
possible two-on-one led by Reinhardt Heckman lson
shoots rebound available but Primo the Stop and
a two-on-one the other way maybe a three-on-one
for Montreal ol leads the rush Baron UL chip
job and bski was there save percentage his 22nd
career start tonight the puck pops back after the
offensive opportunity get it to the middle of the
ice make a decision from there Puck entry fre and
using his body to protect the puck as well Montour
slings it on that Good zp by Sam Bennett in front
and again Kaden Primo back again intended for new
hook he gets taken down again this time by kulakov
but Suzuki's on the Pu ni Suzuki wrist shot and up
top Baron wrist shot that missed everything went
wide for hiy I slot Monahan spitting towards the
net bski there and ready there is no quit number
11 on each and every ship lot of board battle by
Brennan Gallagher marov drops it off richan
Rodriguez up high and handled Again by Primo
he's been sharp in this first period for Montreal
up top forsling big rocket and Primo steers that
into the corner good on Josh Anderson and that's
who that player has been he hasn't quit during
this Dro as Lou theen and W up short headed
and Primo's just going to hold that four on
four continues here's bour he'll bring it to
the line drops for Bennett kachu R shot just
wide Far Side Matthew kachak Let it Fly Boy the
defenseman have been jumping up in the play Hayden
gy with a great burst there kachu approaching a
100 shots this season enters the night fifth in
the National Hockey League and he didn't miss by
much there here's Baron strubel shoots up high
bski as Jaden strel key phrase you new there is
helping out you need help along the boards they
do such a good job of squeezing and you need help
knock Luen Gayden ghouly far Corner he'll chip it
off the GL into Center Jake Evans cutting in
Evans delays wait shoot sto by verovski Nick
Suzuki plays it around the boards Lindstrom no
hook look go tough pass in a two-on one here's
barov Alexander barov shoots score the Icebreaker
barkoff and it's one nothing Florida 42 points in
32 career games versus Montreal because in four
on four the defensive responsibilities are really
defined so you've got the two forwards you can
see barov just cheating out and the second that
pass comes across he's jumping that play that's
a play that Lindstrom simply cannot make m mlo is
there real good stick by strubel and he's on the
Move Jaden strubel drop pass Jake Evans throws it
in front that shot up top Ulin handled by bosski
Giger Over The Line slowski in you're eyes slowski
couldn't get a good shot away Pearson shoot stop
Giger in front Puck still L Gallagher's helmets
off as he got up ended he's got to get the helmet
back on he knows it just rolls a little bit he
gets a little deaf little pass back right there
it just slides off it does go in off the pad an
is too close to make a play and then it's Brandon
Gallagher party time in front of the net bski busy
this season 18th game of the year that's time
for the N the future and promise of Montreal's
D to be leading the entire leag in total goals
Ken gly a big part of that underway here in this
third period Veri swings at the puck the chu goes
to the net Bennett shoots scores Sam Bennett with
the rocket for his third of the season and 8
seconds in it's two and nothing Florida play
as the barov play was two little breakdowns just
off the opening draw here it's just a lean in by
Justin Baron that little step up right there cost
him Bennett slides in behind him there's nobody
covering just the reach in the neutral zone and
Baron's just got to protect the defensive side
of that play they are going to play smart and
conservative all over the ice chance to pick up
five out of a possible six points on this this
Canadian swing they'll head home and host the
Islanders on Saturday R shot Rodriguez scores
up top Evan Rodriguez his fourth of the season
and Florida some big time Insurance a three
nothing lead Sam rard with a little drop pass
Devon Rodriguez coming and we just talked about
them playing conservative and yeah that play is
not screened at all that is just a shot that beats
an NHL goalie from the tops the circles already
has two shut outs this season bov stick shatters
allows Evans to break away with Gallagher gager
Evans in shoots at a good glove stop AB Browski
Jake Evans when you look at this franchise bosski
is in at two more seasons at 10 million per
they don't have a first round pick till 2026
as Veri shoots score on Q Carter ver Hai a power
play goal it is 4 nothing [Applause] Florida
accountable in all of Florida goal strong
wrist shots to the glove side of Kaden Primo
that one blows right by by eight terrific
shooter Carter ragi Jaden strubel under
some pressure nice pass to hesitate get it
to Evans pfield on the Move strubel behind
him as strubel goes in deep Cofield
protects the puck slings it up kovich
he shoots scar over the CL into the net k s
gred it right [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] through we talked about
kovich and the opportunities he was getting
that he was going to score at some time but some
Nifty work along the boards strouble with a Cole
Coffield high slot drops it off bar it in shot
rebound b a hand stopped by MOSI they cashed
in on their opportunities James Duffy in his
interview with Matthew kuk earlier this week
and he said we can play the game any way
we want to play it now they've learned a
lot as emman lson winds up scores Oliver emman
LaRon absolutely rips one for the Blue Line it's
51 traffic Crossing in front of Kaden Primo have
been part of the issue here watch as the puck goes
from side to side Nick cousins wins his initial
battle and it was traffic Crossing in front the
vision of Kaden Creo taken away 27 goals last
year in the four games and it was dominated by
Florida and on this night Sergey bosi will pick up
the win 51 the final bosski 11 wins on the season